yo bootleg cat podcast
we got my guy spiffy Luciano with the
builder man no son we're about to have
him uh do what he came to do and let's
wrap his ass off let's just get right to
it go watch the full interview enter uh
of course the albums come on top of the
Year parody motions shout out my guy
Boosie man shout out Boosie come on
let's get it bro
[Music]
they tried to tell me it was luck but
there's some [ __ ] that I was destined
for heavy in the streets it's amazing we
survived War seen a lot of [ __ ] and did
a lot so now it's time to score trying
to get my mom all Section 8 we still
kind of poor thought that we was cool
and we were stuck and trying to break
the law me and Barry all that makes we
stealing all the polo draw me to back
the bridge and Squad will up and
breaking [ __ ] jaw jumping on that 108
bus and take it to the show try to do my
best cause I ain't want my mama mad at
me mama was at work we had a shootout
with my step daddy popped it up to win
clean the house or you wasn't happy I
love you when I forget you act like it
never happened know that I'm a ride or
die for you if I call you family they
Judge Me by my lips until I make them
understand me anti-social I ain't
friendly love my man my granny cuz it's
probably trying to kill me money make
them [ __ ] every day hate that I'm
doing better hate that I ain't in them
trenches I ain't never been to break the
doctors it's a part of living before
it's time God gonna bless me with a
hundred million with a couple big ass
houses and a couple children what a girl
that love my soul that's gonna protect
my feelings that's one of mys I promise
you and yours wrong with him I clutch
that eye cause I don't trust and now I'm
feeling [ __ ] I don't gotta point to
prove that make me blood [ __ ] we ain't
had [ __ ] at home at school selling my
lunch tickets scraping dollars up so we
could eat some friends and mama's
chicken can't complain I'm doing better
Dr Death and duck in prison [ __ ]
Overkill my daddy how the [ __ ] I'm gonna
forget what forget them take it up with
God I know they hate it cuz I don't like
to meet new [ __ ] no I don't want you
love I don't want you [ __ ] fake doubts
and I don't want your hug watch the ones
around me they be faking like they [ __ ]
with us they fake like they [ __ ] with me
for years but I just take the road doing
all this pain I feel divide the devil
want my soul can't complain I'm doing
right yeah [ __ ] know the truth
I see what the [ __ ] going on Kev [ __ ]
buried emotions buried emotions I've
been hot I've been the hardest show me
your talent [ __ ] get your talent up
spiffy Luciano
damn
[ __ ]
shout out Boosie [ __ ]
you know what's going on that's hard bro
so good looking yeah
hey we just ended a freestyle uh shout
out to our family at LRG you'll see the
new LRG you know Ewing athletic collab
go to lrg's website right now
l-r-g.com and use the promo code bootleg
and you'll save 30 off at checkout
that's a serious amount of money to save
especially during the holidays shout out
to LRG we got another freestyle dropping
[ __ ] maybe this week definitely next
week though let's go